we see a lot of sort figures numbers or
kind of have small things are getting in
computing right and I thought who better
to talk to than sixty symbols is own
would you quit up a nano scientist oh I
guess I would it depends on which
funding agency I'm applying to funding
for but yeah nanoscientist is a good one
here yeah it's great to be back in
computer file it's been a long time I
don't know a couple of years something
like that um so yeah we do within the
group here we manipulate individual
items that's that's what we do so we
work at the level of not just single
atoms and single molecules but actually
looking inside single molecules the
state of the art is no longer at least
in the research and development
community not in the commercial
community but in the industrial
community but in the search and
development particularly universities
state of the art isn't see in atoms
we've been able to do that for years in
fact we could see atoms or as long ago
as 1955 with something called the field
iron microscope beginning of eighties
however at all Chin's because it was an
instrument called the scanning tunneling
microscope developed which is basically
a sharp probe you bring it in close to a
surface you move it back and forth and
you measure a force or an interaction
and the important thing is we can make
this probe atomically sharp then your
resolutions is up a single item level so
we can see atoms we can move them but as
I say the state of the art is actually
single bonds looking at single electron
orbitals single chemical bonds and
manipulating those commercially that
technology doesn't exist and it's going
to be quite a while before we get down
to devices which are truly mass-produced
at the single item level but if you look
at the you know from the 70s I think
we're at the sort of 10 micrometer
levels so 10 micrometer micrometer is a
thousandth of a millimeter millionth of
a meter we're now at the 14 nanometer
level but so the really off hand where
and to try and get some vague handle on
it is for many of you out there perhaps
not for me but for many of you out there
your hair will grow roughly about a
nanometer a second particularly if you
knew you know teens twenties your hair
is grown at about that rate of about a
nanometer a second in the context of
single
atoms the diameter of an atom is about a
few tenths of a nanometer when we're
working at 14 nanometers and the feature
sizes on semiconductor chips are around
about 40 nanometers we're talking you
know tens of atoms we're talking of the
order of 50 60 atoms wide the features
so it's a is really quite remarkable you
know we went from thousandth of a
millimeter down to 50 atoms in the
course of you know for 50 years
something like that
so you mentioned the features is that
things like the individual wires that go
to make it right yes yeah exactly that's
exactly sort it's the feature size
really is to do with the the all the
different elements on the chip in terms
largely the transistors and the wiring
and the different types of component you
have on the chip that have been just
scaled all the way down to that level at
the moment and the way it works in the
way it's worked for decades is that you
control the where the electrons are you
control the electron charge and
electrons will respond to electric
fields so if you've got a battery and or
you've got two two metal plates and you
put a battery across them what you have
between those plates is what's called an
electric field you put an electron in
there then that electron will respond to
the electric field a great deal of the
electronics around us is based on
silicon there are other compounds things
like called gallium arsenide for example
but a great deal of the the micro and
nano electronics industry is based on
silicon so there's a silicon work a bit
like the plastic that you maybe or the
PCB if I say green PCB that's plastic
with wires on does this oh that's also
that's a really good question no the
silicon is much more active than that
much more active it's not like you put
on these features on the silicon is just
a passive substrate you're actually
using the silicon and the electrons in
the silicon and you're controlling where
the electrons in the silicon go and you
can take the raw silicon and you can
dope it you can add impurities
deliberately to add to introduce more
electrons or indeed actually to take
electrons out so we've got electrons and
holes and that means you can contain
jerem attica lee how when you put a
battery on this thing or when you put a
power source on it how those electrons
flow and then by in there in turn
patterning little metal features on top
of that you
apply electric fields and you can
control where the electrons go well you
generally switch ON or switch off the
flow of the electrons you trap the
electrons in a region of space now the
problem is with this technology is that
it's starting to run out of steam it's
been running out of steam for quite some
time and there's been lots of near
seeing going on since the early eighties
saying that is going to stop and it's
going to fail in snowing and the the
semiconductor industry is extremely
clever and comes up with new ideas time
and time again but you can't beat
physics we are going to come very soon
particularly you were now at tens of
atoms when we get down to features which
are just a few atoms or say 10 atoms
across then we've got to take into
account that once you get down to that a
level it's quantum which means that you
can no longer just think of the electron
as a little hard billiard board which is
the picture all of us have in our heads
it's actually got a wave-like character
which is not to say it would be easy if
it were just that the electrons spread
out in space that's not what happens it
means that it under certain
circumstances it behaves as if it were a
wave and if you find out confusing good
because so many of us find it confusing
this is this is this is raw quantum
physics this is as a physicist it's not
that you understand it you just get used
to it so but once you get down to this
level though you get this wave-like
characteristic and then just like waves
waves will spread out so you might want
to trap the electron in this region of
space but it's starting now
due to this really small size - we're at
the point where we've got to take out
wave like nature into consideration and
the electron can spread out we call that
tunneling and that means you want to
trap it in space but in fact you just
can't it's so slippery it's tunneling
away so I'm going to throw a really
stupid question so I'm full of them
today and I've heard that quantum
computing is a good thing so I mean I
sort of sort know so there's a
difference yeah right so there's a
quantum computing which is where you
absolutely exploit that so there is
classical computing which what we have
now and then we have quantum computing
now those are two very very different
paradigms so instead this is quantum
effects on classical computers perfect
yes
quantum effects on classical computing
instead of just
being pure quantum the sort of mindset
in the industry and the mindset in some
areas of academia is how do we work
around these effects I think we're going
to have to start particularly at the end
of this really small sizes we're going
to have to stop seeing them as something
that's you know to the detriment of the
device and Exploited instead I'm going
to have to think about well we can do
amazing things when we start thinking of
that wave-like character and the move to
what more a more towards a much more
sort of quantum mindset where instead of
trying to work around these things we
exploit them so we work with silicon a
great deal in the lab it's quite shiny
it is very very shiny so it's polished
on that side so when we do our
experiments to manipulate atoms we take
a chunk of this a little bit less than a
centimeter square something like that we
put it in an ultra-high vacuum and we
heat it up to about 1,200 degrees C and
that drives off the oxide that is on the
surface and just after it cools down we
can see atoms so they're really it's
actually quite straightforward these
days to see individual atoms and silicon
surfaces that's not how the
semiconductor industry works because to
see individual atoms particularly the
way we do it and the way many other
groups in the world do it it takes many
hours to get to get good images to form
the components and to pattern the wafer
you use something called
photolithography or in something called
electron beam lithography and photo
lithography has been the standard
throughout the industry for very very
many years but it's again running out of
steam so you checked away for you coated
with a thin film of polymer or plastic
and then you put a what's called a mask
in front of it or stencil basically and
then you shine light through that
stencil and you expose the plastic at
the surface in particular regions
according to the pattern and the
important thing is when this particular
polymer is exposed to light it becomes
soluble if the regions that aren't
exposed aren't soluble so then you can
put it in an etch and you can remove
those those regions where it's been
soluble and leave those regions where
its own soluble that's the fundamental
process that's the fundamental process
in a nutshell and they do different
layers of this as well so it's extremely
clever because you're limited by the
natural
wavelength of light so light has a
wavelength and therefore that wavelength
ultimately determines the feature size
and with the current processing which is
about 40 nanometers they do something
really really clever which is they use
one mask exposed and then they put
another mask and they just offset it a
little bit which is really clever and
given that this is 40 nanometers when I
say a little bit that's a teensy tiny
tiny bit and that actually getting those
in registry is is quite tricky so that's
that's where the industry is at the
moment to go beyond that really to get
down to these features which are ten
atoms of a few atoms across then you
have to start thinking about lots of
other issues and lots of other
approaches one way of doing that is to
move to a much shorter wavelength and
what shorter wavelength means much
higher energy and we have something
called extreme ultraviolet so that's far
off the end of the ultraviolet range and
you can get down to the standard their
aiming for is 13.5 nanometers light
wavelength light and they that's quite
equating high in energy is really high
in energy and that will enable you to
get the feature size much much smaller
you can really push the resolution you
can really push the feature size down by
using instead of photons of light using
electrons and you can squeeze the
wavelength of electrons down much much
smaller the problem with that is is it's
a serial eight you just you have your
sample you have your wafer and then you
just bear that in light with electrons
it's a raster beam which means it's a
instead of a parallel process it's a
serial process which means it's
incredibly slow so electron being gives
you much better definition a much better
resolution but it just for the
semiconductor industry it's a real pain
because it's so unbelievably slow so the
the for us when we manipulate atoms it's
exactly the same process we use a single
probe we bring it in close to a surface
we can see atoms and we can manipulate
those atoms or move them and bullets
it's excruciatingly ly slow because it's
a serial process this is the crystal
structure of silicon just assume that
all the atoms are the same color
each sphere each board represents a
single silicon atom and the silicon
crystallizes in a form where you've got
these tetrahedron so if we take one
silicon atom here it's purple one it's
connected to one two three four and
that's because in chemical terms silicon
has four valence electrons it wants to
form four valence bonds there are so
many we have these really silly at times
and frustrating this is chemistry and
this is physics when it's all part of
one integrated whole even computer
science is part of that integrated whole
sometimes
so but that's sort of off the point of
what we were discussing it's fun but
just to show you in action that